[Music]  jack  this thing between us i can't deny it  anymore i don't know jimmy i must have  you  okay yes to all of this  anyone want to get this train back on  track  you're a  tiger  [Applause]  oh god i'm so stressed and my hair is  falling out  look at that it just falls out  uniforms promote conformity okay you're  gonna turn these kids into mindless  zombies like a cult i do not see that  happening  we're really getting somewhere now  faculty and students we are officially  in a tornado warning copper derms will  keep you safe  we're all dead no we're dead no do not  live in fear  [Music]  now i have something to say to you and i  want you to listen very carefully can  you please just confirm that you didn't  kill anyone i have a go bag boss  whatever you need no questions asked  where's my son jack it's not like him to  be late i imagine whoa  are you mr mr griffin i suppose i am dad  my god look how big you are been the  size for over 20 years holy sh  ready to begin  you